the most important thing that you can do
in this world is to think about the
balanced work life I always begin with
the end in mind what would you want them
to say about you when you're not around
I don't think it's that you always got
in first and left last and missed
everything that really mattered in life
so I've always tried to prioritize my
marriage my children my family above
everything else because in the end those
are the things that will be here when
everything else is long gone
so I truly believe the prioritization of
family in business cannot be strongly
stressed enough by any executive because
the best executives are the ones that
have always put family first it also
makes them much more productive in the
office I get credit at home for being a
good executive in the office but the
credit that I'm really interested in is
in my good dad I'm a good husband and if
I can pull that off as well as being a
good brother and a good son I'm much
more productive in my work life so this
is the balance that we all have to work
for each and every day but I encourage
my people don't miss a birthday unless
you absolutely have no way out give it
everything you can to be there for the
important moments the office will find a
way to compensate for that gap it'll
show people around you that you're a
company that stands for more than just
the bottom line you stand for something
that will endure the test of time and I
truly believe in the end as we look back
on this life that we've lived that's a
much more enduring legacy than whatever
happened he always drove the top and the
bottom line we know who exactly who he
was you know I'll give you a couple of
examples you know when I was a
hard-driving Young Salesman in New York
City when my friend Richard Reid who was
a colleague in the sales department had
a young baby girl I dropped everything
on my canvas
day two show up at Lenox Hill Hospital
with flowers for him and his wife to
demonstrate my total respect for him
when we lost David Kearns from this
world who was the CEO at Xerox when I
was 21 that I wanted to be in the
winner's dream I was the first one other
than his direct family that was at his
funeral home to celebrate his life so I
think there are just certain things
about how you live your life and the
character and the integrity by which you
live your life that will endure all the
business stuff and that's part of being
a winner and that's part of living the
dream